salut les cocos c'est mister perrier ce
que tu fous là était en train de vous
piquer le travail sur ma chaîne c'est la
chaîne la whey je voyais des abonnés au
jeu me piquer tous mes abonnés suffit
maintenant
ici c'est chez moi là bas maintenant ça
chez moi c'est chez toi ravisseurs on
est chez soi on est en suisse
et oui merci mais que y'a rien je peux
prendre la charge qui permet de
[Musique]
sont sympas ces suisses mais vouloir
donner ça ils vous prennent c'est comme
ça que ça se passe
est ce que ça joue bien ça joue bien
c'est chez toi
non mais parce qu aujourd hui explique
bon déjà on va vous dire bonjour bonjour
à tous à lui bienvenue sur ma chaîne
monsieur greuze je suis aujourd'hui en
suisse en celui-ci avec miss me
suiciderai rigolo celui-ci avec mister
perrier et je suis venu voir parce que
je trouvais que mr perrier avec des
choses formidables à raconter et
justement il va nous les raconter alors
c'est quoi cette expression ça joue bien
elle joue via c'est quoi ce truc ça veut
dire ça va ça va ça va ça va ça va bien
sûr un super merci m'accueillir en
suisse on est bien ouais en suisse on
est bien les jamais il énergie qu'un
ingéré patatras
alors aujourd'hui l'histoire perrier
n'accueille nous accueillent tous
ensemble pour parler d'apple la marque à
la pomme parce que ce mec là il a une
collection c'est même pas une collection
s'amuser c'est à dire que vous avez vu
signer tu nous a réservé une petite
sélection maison tout à fait thierry
depuis le temps ce monsieur je vous
affirme ce n'est pas une expression un
peu su stade su aussi de noter vous a
fait une sélection on a tracé l'histoire
d'apple 1to travers de grands produits
phares tu m'a montré vite fait tu m'a
dit je te le monde je te lis rien est
loin de la vie éco tu me dis rien comme
ça je découvre en même temps nous on va
regarder ça ensemble et je pense qu'un
truc où la mort est du lot des cartes et
ça fait super mal
cela devrait vous abordez donc le bronze
par quoi commencer on commence par quoi
par le commencement
le taekwondo la plus mc intosh plus
regardent comme il
[Musique]
alors steve jobs a ils se prenaient en
photo avec ses il faisait le un peu son
yoga avec l adorer sa petite bête vous
voyez pas derrière un megabit one
megabyte j'ai des petites [ __ ] accusés
- jeu oui on a créé ce schéma là on a
craché sur l'objectif à c'est mieux
comme ça il me semblait que c'était un
match qui était sa maison non non ça va
mieux mais c'est bon on continue il est
sorti qu'on en quelle année sur 80 4984
oui la corniche et aux 84 84
il est sorti en 84 d'accord 1984 celle
débuts d'apple c'est le début d'un
malware
c'est le début de la commercialisation
des premiers ordinateurs grand public
tout en un donc on a convié souris et
lausanne petite souris ou et mulot
normalement c'est un peu gris n'as-tu
pas remarquer qu'avec lui il n'y a pas
que nous il n'y a pas que nous comptons
nîmes edmond valoir celui à qui je les
achetais qui il fut métro d'euros de ces
gars là toi c'est pas bien voilà c'est
pas bien d'accord total petit mulot avec
tu avais le clavier et tout est là
dedans tout est là dedans donc lecteur
de disquettes intégré par contre
portables etc dot a pour lancer le
système skull lancé à partir de la
disquette
donc si tu voulais lancer d'autres
programmes tu devais acheter un lecteur
externe tu devais repasser à la caisse
tu vois déjà à l'époque il est déjà très
très fort un peu le niveau dit d'accord
qu'ils ont compris bon il faut dépasser
la caisse deux fois un formidable
donc ça c'est la machine 1984
commercialisé pendant combien de temps à
peu près écoute pendant pas mal d'années
après il ya d'autres versions y ait des
versions améliorées
ouais ça a été ça a été l'étendard
d'apple pendant active tu n'es pas sans
savoir peut-être que steve jobs s'est
fait virer de sa propre entreprise
bye bye si par monsieur john solide qui
était le patron de chez pecsi d'accord
c'est lui qui allait le recruter un don
pour devenir directeur de chez apple ce
seuil au hockey et il lui a dit tu veux
continuer à vendre des boissons sucrées
ou tu veux changer bon ouais elle a dit
beaucoup je pars avec toi et quelques
quelques mois plus tard ben ils le
virent est avec le toute l'assemblée
j'ai donc le macintosh plus parce que
c'est un truc qui a marché un peu ou pas
du tout ça a marché mais c'était pas
c'est pas les scores d'aujourd'hui tout
le monde ne pouvait pas se payer ça en
parlant mettait dans plus de 1000 $ tu
par la sonde en ont laissé à plus de
1000 $ on est très près de 1000 $ ok ok
donc là on est vraiment sur les produits
qui sont faits plus pour une élite
exactement exactement alors ce n'était
pas le but de steve jobs
au départ c'était de remettre un peu
dans tous les foyers s'étaient pas à
grand tirage
ouais comme aujourd'hui donc les marges
étaient pas et même si jobs et est plus
là ok mais il revient en 1997 il dit
j'en ai marre de ces ordinateurs tout
gris de mal à jamais dans la couleur
comme puissant la demeco rens il est
allé chercher un anglais qui s'appelle
j'en aie aie aux [ __ ] nature il faut
qu'ils passent de la musculation à eau
comme il est bon que tu viennes la
couche et celui un vrai ce que je t'ai
bien que c'est diviser
quelle année 97 97 retour de steve jobs
welcome 98 il sort cette petite bête et
c'est de la soupe faisait dagorn jamais
terme à l'europe
sûrement oui moi je fais ça tu le
censurer tout ça ah ouais ouais c'est
ouais mais puisque tu attaques aux
attentes du tube cathodique à
l'intérieur septembre alors là sur le
côté donc là j'ai tous les pores on vous
le donne pas forcément je pars gros zoom
est donc là on a quoi lasser du firewire
les vieux c'est bien pourquoi y en avait
avant usb moderne et art et nadal a
breaké micro entre eux par leur sortie
casque une sortie sortie qui s'enrichit
de repérer ce qui se bornait hockey et
ouais t'as vraiment le tube cathodique
l'année c'est incroyable donc ça c'est
98 donc ça c'est vraiment le début ou le
grand retour à port de steve jobs en
laye mac succès commercial voilà et
c'est là où apple commence vraiment à
devenir un peu les pub télé pub qui vont
bien mais avec les toutes les couleurs
ça faisait une petite fleur et donc
premier design de japan rail donc qui
est le designer maintenant phare de chez
apple toujours toujours il s'occupe même
maintenant de du design
logiciel est abondante à 17 pour le
lecteur cd à ok et après on aura
d'autres versions plus tard qu'ils vont
sortir avec le lecteur dvd et au tout
départ c'était pas un manche 10 comme on
a là c'était le titre offre mais eu deux
trois petits accidents vu le poids
aujourd'hui j'ai souvent et la toque est
super donc ça s'ajuste commercial et
c'est vraiment jeudi une nouvelle
approche
exactement la remontée de la stib est
parti c'était le gros boxant commandité
une ensemble bonsoir bons et parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre 84 et 90
est chef de file et bien terminé la
culture physique on a aussi se sont
faits un peu de culture c'est la seule
astuce on se sent obligé d'être au
niveau avec egis jeu mais que milo
endesa appareil est d'ailleurs de mettre
un peu ce que tu es donc qu'est ce qui
s'est passé entre 88 84 et 90 est fiable
sur l'apple c'était trop beau rien ça a
été un gros banc pendant 14 ans cette
boîte à la fait rien du tout aussi si il
ya eu des sorties et des sorties mais il
ya plus de ya plus de succès aucun
appareil n'a vraiment pris pas tous et
commerciales non bon ben tant pis pour
eux alors après et moi en fait fais moi
rêver je voyageais dans le temple dans
le temps à autre je le vois quel est cet
objet alors la mise comme 1999 où 99 ou
le maïs et l'e-mail 99 pour l'audience
suisse héberge
je suis désolé pour l'instant je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est passé je me sente
obligé poignée foyer facile après on a
vu que c'est nulle part une fois qu'ils
ont braqué d'ailleurs si c'était une
idée
et on va passer à autre chose ok joli
panier superboy ouvre le dire je vais le
chercher comme un ace c'est un piège là
tu me tend un piège ouvre le parce
qu'elle se ferait par taratata
tu me fais un piège et un piège un piège
à c est en train de vouloir piéger
français tu t il y tient le suisse va se
payer un français est le truc comment ça
s'ouvre non non non je veux trouver
parce que c'est peut-être déjà que le
capteur le médium la pomme non il ya
forcément un truc pratique c'est
forcément tous qui réfléchit forcément
on doit mettre quelque part oui c'était
pas mal de vent ok tout ce bleu celui de
hockey donc ça ouais ibook de ouf
d'accord donc ça c'est complètement
est-ce que tu le trouve jolie écoute je
sais pas je trouve qu'il a un look
particulier j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression que c'est la vision de
l'ordinateur portable depuis les années
70 et son surnom
ibook ibooks et son nom mais son surnom
quel surnom et lyon 2 avec moi à quoi il
ressemble il ressemble à quelque chose
on trouve dans la nature d'une pomme a
eu du mal à l'ouvrir déjà un coquillage
voilà une palourde une palourde ils
n'ont pas appelé la palourde et oui la
fin ça donne en anglais ça donne quoi la
palourde clim check in chelles un truc
ce que ça ok on peut chercher non non
non non c'est ne pas savoir où malherbe
est ce assez la palourde la tonne bon
alors quelle année je te le dis tout à
l'heure je me souviens plus 1900 il
voulait m'avoir je ne passe avec 1999 il
ya les titres leurs neuf voilà je moi je
dois faire les affaires de la traduction
lors sa mère avec son c'est compliqué
d'accord ça c'est la palourde apple donc
là on a un lecteur disque ou pas là
dessus
et oui alors main électroniques juste là
tu vas tu appuies sur ce petit bouton
aller au clash et sa centaine entraîne
donc la ja lecteur disque voyage le
risque on a donc parlé tactile ipad et
tactile super souris qui cliquent voilà
les droits des ligues auch ouais ok
génial chose qu'il faut les petits
raccourcis qui vont bien et est déjà là
haut parleurs ou par leurs environs pas
sur le mois mono romain rolland et
particularités que des chers abonnés et
mes futurs abonnés mélodrame y de hockey
avec voilée sur les deux façons c'est
l'amitié franco suisse exactement un
problème là la pomme et d'alembert
ah oui la pomme est à l'envers à
l'endroit de deux dents et allant même à
l'extérieur d'accord pourquoi parce que
monsieur steve il se disait que quand
l'eau va on va regarder lymphome du bon
côté on doit voir la pomme du bon goût
tout d'abord la marque du bon du coup
ils n'ont pas réfléchi a surpris tu vois
ils l'ont finalement changé que vous me
dans le sens malin ce style d'accord
superbe elle pas lourd donc là on est en
mode entre 9,99 pour les gens normaux
grand succès commercial ça ça cartonne
ça ça cartonne ça ça cartonne parce que
c'est vraiment le renouveau d'apple
version en direct important
voilà bien une vague cette bague de
couleurs déjà ça fait un truc même même
même les pc ils sont tous grille
des modèles qui sont sorties plus pros
comme le prisme le monstre ça c'est le
mans ça c'est le modèle ça tape un logo
dessus et à un logo dessous on dirait
presque l'ordinateur gamers aujourd'hui
les enfilades je vais les jantes ne vous
énervez parfait ne vous énervez pas ah
ouais si m c'est très très d'accord donc
ça c'est triste mais au à loeb
à l'aube du xxième siècle la lan
connecteurs double firewire
tu as la sortie vga taha melon c'est
beau velvet y avait déjà une
segmentation des gannes public
professionnel c'est à dire que le grand
public on lui envoie la couleur et on
fait la fête c'est de la fantaisie le
professionnel et du noir et puis
maintenant on peut se rendre compte
qu'un autre époque ça fusionnent un
petit peu voilà ce qu'il ya pratiquement
que des modèles truman modèle et blanc
un imac l'épisode mcb l'enquêté en tout
temps classiques qu'ils ont complètement
disparu des listes mario dont on sait
qu'on a un peu une fusion des deux
domaines nous en vivons dans les années
2000 ça je n'ai jamais vu de ma vie j'ai
leucate d'accord surnommé le tube mercy
sauf que vous avez jamais eu d'accord
donc ça c'est le g4 cube dont cet acte a
huit puissances dans ce petit tube la
table unité centrale dessus vous avez
une espèce de vente je peux le soulever
et à sucre et l'eau j'ai l'impression
voilà ce qu'écrit longtemps une espèce
de ventilation sur le dessus alors là il
ya un bouton power to mix est en contact
il exactement
le système de ventilation c'est le même
que sur les derniers mac pro tu sais
qu'il avait sorti en forme conique
c'est un système qui doit qui traverse
la bête l'accord anti l'accord au milieu
il ça passe vraiment je danse vraiment
c'est à dire que là je vous vois à
travers l'incroyable vous voyez pas mais
moi je le vois ok super donc là t'es
fait qu tivement sur le cube logique a
donc la fin de la puissance à l'état pur
made in apple avec un produit hyper
design un espèce de plexi autour
exactement
super cool super beau et physique en
plus sûr il ya une particularité qui
pouvaient plus avoir chez aujourd'hui
cheryl cole exactement à une autre ne
l'est déjà c'est un échec commercial
ça ça ils sont plantés ils se sont
plantés pourquoi trop cher un con et ça
coûtera entre 1700 1800 $ pour la petite
config et après on monte à 2000
en 2005 donc là ils ont joué sur le
produit on est hyper très bien commencé
le bo premium chef alors particularité
qu'on trouve plus maintenant sur les mac
c'est cette petite poignée mes chers
amis olala mais regardez on n'atteint
toujours imposant de la bête disque dur
g
y a que la carte graphique que je pense
qu'on peut pas changer
on l'a bien précieux dans sa bouche
parti c'est quoi ça c'est une fois ci
dessus une pile fait ça c'est une fille
sassine piles au lithium ça ouais
exactement là on est une fille donc là
on a le disque dur ici énormes disques
durs eater mastoc et on a accès à tout
alors j'ai un truc tu as lorsque tu vois
la marque mais maintenant il ya marqué
en gros la foxconn alors foxconn c'est
pas ça vous parle c'est un fournisseur
mais qu'ils nous fournissent armes il
possède avec eux depuis énormément et
apple bosse encore faudrait-il foxconn
pour les iphone pour normalement de
exact de produits c'est un truc de des
normes et ventes l'a donc la tâche je
n'ai jamais tu pouvais changer tout ce
que tu voulais monter tard à changer de
disque dur tu pouvais atteindre des
choses qu'aujourd'hui c'est strictement
impossible
exactement alors la connectique c'est la
même en garde du fire island l'éternel
de l'usb et par écoute là tu arrivais
set c'était exprès pour les cinema
display de chez apple
ça c'est très très bon très très beau
mais à l'échec c'est à dire que c'est
une belle réussite d'un point de vue
esthétique nabonne du commercial
comme dirait l'autre merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo le roi
albert en plusieurs parties parce que mr
parié il ya tellement de choses à nous
montrer que vont d'une fois c'est pas
possible
donc restez connectés abonnez-vous si ce
n'est pas déjà fait face le verre plein
plein plein de choses à venir
qui nous dit pas mais il ya vachement de
surprise de choses qui vont arriver
il avait la première partie était
extraordinaire la deuxième et ont
renvoyé les aidants comme on dit chez
nous tof de crit
merci beaucoup merci à vous n'hésitez
pas à me laisser des commentaires à me
dire ce que vous pensez qu'elle est
votre histoire avec apple est ce quelque
chose qui sont cools des choses pas cool
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs aussi
ce que souvent grandiose
à travers les marques caisse qui a
marqué votre histoire avec les produits
apple vous ne marquez tout ça en
commentaire bien évidemment on reste
connectés
je vous embrasse êtes au top n'hésitez
pas à rester connectés abonnez-vous à la
chaîne de mr feriez vous allez bien
évidemment à laisser connectée à vous
abonner aux séries mais parce qu'avec
toujours plus et toujours mieux de teck
a bientôt mais sans parier pour la
deuxième partie on sera un tchèque
royaume et à bientôt